All right.
We've been talking about
a code of representations in some sense
of symbolic representation and I've been trying to guide you through some
developing understanding of that code of symbolic representation so that as we
progress through the course,
you'll have the ground rules in some sense for interpreting all the different
theories that we encounter.
And we're going to continue that today.
This is the last lecture on sort of pre psychoanalytic conceptions of
personality and then we moved to Piaget and then to you.
So
the first thing I tried to point out to you was that social primates like us
likely have a cognitive structure that's based on social categories and that
when our cognitive systems elaborate it up enough to start thinking about the
world in more abstract terms beyond our immediate environment,
there's a high probability that we learned,
we used the same cognitive structures that had evolved to begin the process of
abstract conceptualization.
And so in some sense you could say we used our knowledge of personality to start
to understand the external world based on the initial axiomatic assumption.
It's not a cognitive assumption.
It was a perceptual assumption that the world was like a personality.
And we do this automatically.
So I want to show you a little video here.
This is quite a famous video.
Um,
it shows you how easily you can abstract out and narrative from the most
abstract of events.
Okay,
so watch what happens.
let's watch that one more time.
So it's something like,
we'll go over it again.
It's something like the little circle.
The poor little circle is trying to escape and when it does,
the bad gray triangle comes up and sort of steals it.
And then a blue triangle has a little scrap with the gray triangle and puts the
little yellow or the little circle back into its safe and closure.
Right?
And so the,
the reason that that demonstration was developed was to indicate or two and also
to test how little information you really needed,
how low resolution the information was that you needed in order to perceive,
to directly perceive.
That was like a narrative.
So,
you know,
and that's a relatively complicated narrative.
All things considered for a square two triangles and a circle interacting for
maybe three or four seconds.
So,
you know,
the,
the point of this demonstration is to indicate just exactly how prepared you are
to read the world in narrative terms.